hey this is preshtal Walker here's an
interesting question we have a large
circle with chord PQ
above the chord we have a small circle
that's tangent to the chord and touching
the large Circle
below the chord PQ we have another
Circle that's tangent to the chord and
touching the large Circle and the two
small circles are touching each other
all three Circle centers are aligned
if PQ is equal to six what is the area
that's shaded in blue which is the area
between the two small circles and the
large Circle
this is from the ukmt IMC 2023 question
25 and I thank Max and asir for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
I'll present two ways to solve the
problem the first method uses a right
triangle and the second method uses the
chord cord power theorem
let's get started with method one
let's work this out carefully suppose
the top Circle has radius equal to a
suppose the bottom Circle has radius
equal to B and suppose that b is greater
than a
now the diameter of the top Circle will
be equal to 2A and the diameter of the
bottom Circle will be equal to 2B
suppose the large Circle has radius
equal to R
we know that the span of the two
diameters of these small circles will
span the diameter of the large Circle so
we have 2R is equal to two a plus 2B and
that means R is equal to a plus b
now we want to calculate the Shaded area
this will be the area of the large
Circle minus the areas of the small
circles so it will be pi r squared minus
Pi a squared minus pi b squared but we
know that R is equal to a plus b so we
can substitute in
then we can expand out this binomial
now we can do some cancellation
we can cancel out Pi a squared and pi b
squared leaving the Shaded area is equal
to 2 a b pi so this is our goal that we
want to calculate and we'll keep that in
mind
now we know the radius of the large
circle is equal to a plus b let's find
the distance from the center of this
circle to the chord PQ
how can we do that
we'll draw this radius of the large
Circle and we know that it's equal to a
plus b
then we want to subtract out the
diameter of the small circle so we want
to do a plus B minus 2A
so this will be R minus 2A and that'll
be a plus B minus 2A which is equal to B
minus a so this distance is equal to B
minus a
now let's consider this right triangle
where one leg is B minus a the
hypotenuse is a plus b what's the other
leg equal to it's exactly half of PQ so
this triangle will have one leg that's
equal to three which is one half of six
so now in this right triangle we have
the square of a plus b is equal to the
square of B minus a plus the square of
three
we can expand the binomials then cancel
out the a squared and B squared terms so
we get that 4ab is equal to 3 squared
but we know we want to calculate 2 a b
pi
so we divide this equation by 2 and then
multiply both sides of the equation by
pi and that gives us the area 2ab Pi is
equal to 9 pi over 2 and that's one way
to solve the problem
now on to Method two
we will use the chord chord power
theorem
so let's start the problem at this step
where we've calculated the radius of the
large circle is equal to a plus b and we
want to calculate the Shaded area which
is 2 a b pi
so let's say the diameter of the large
Circle has endpoints of s and t and it
intersects the chord PQ at M
by the chord chord power theorem we have
SM multiplied by Mt is equal to PM
multiplied by mq
but SM is equal to 2A Mt is equal to 2B
and then PM is equal to mq which is
equal to half of PQ which equals three
so we have 2A multiplied by 2B is equal
to 3 times 3 which means four a b is
equal to 9. We Now divide both sides by
2 and multiplied by pi to get that 2 a b
Pi is equal to 9 pi over two and that's
another way to solve the problem
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]